so here we have a Republican and Democrat
the Republican Senator Johnson
is a leading peddler of misinformation
while the Democrat is a liberal Democrat
who has been touted as one of the party's rising stars
do we see the bias here
or in other words
the Republican is a evil spreader of misinformation
trying to kill us all versus the Democrat
who's quite literally the second coming of Jesus Christ
look Republican Democrat
they're both 2 sides of the same court
it's not about picking one side or the other
what is important though
is that we have a competent and unbiased
as much as we can
media that's willing to call out both sides
because both sides are people
who are trying to get power over everyone else
and it is the media's job to make sure that
those people trying to get power over all of us
are as well
well equipped as they can possibly be
and you can't have that
when you're playing one side
as favorites over the other